hi I'm Matt Welch for reason TV here at
the conservative political action
conference CPAC over the last few years
has been pretty friendly to the Paul
family both Ron Paul and Rand Paul have
one straw polls in the past that doesn't
necessarily mean that the Republican
Party is ready for a Paul family style
foreign policy of skepticism when it
comes to intervening so we wanted to
find out today what do the party elite
think about when and where and how we
should go to war and how does that
differ from what people from the
grassroots who populate this conference
think so I was just at a foreign policy
debate talking about different
conservative views on foreign policy and
the panelists pretty much agree that we
need to preemptively strike Iran the
preemptive use of military force is also
necessary and appropriate that we need
to drastically increase the defense
budget and and spend a lot more money on
missile defense shields we need to get
way back into the missile defense
business in a big way because we need to
/ / match the threat so massively that
the Iranian weapons look useless do
Proactiv regime change our policy for
the last 15 years should have been and
would be if I became president the
overthrow of the ayatollahs well are
those representative of your views no
that sounds horrible so I just saw you
get your book signed by Senator Rand
Paul what do you think about his foreign
policy compared to that of the others in
the field I think it's much more
responsible i think it's fiscally
conservative so i think other
republicans should be attracted to that
because you know if we're just going to
willy nilly
you know take Congress's war powers away
then we got a problem and we're gonna be
spending a whole lot of money the
younger generation for the most part is
very much anti war ii not crazy about
spending money to go kill people
overseas there are those who want a less
interventionist foreign policy but it is
a lot easier to argue that particular
position when the russian army is in its
barracks drinking vodka i know there's a
wide spectrum of what people think about
pulling out of the world or are being
involved I'm more involved in the world
is the first see packs I went to or
totally kind of socially conservative
that'll triangle but it there weren't
very many libertarians in that triangle
today the last few see packs even more
so there's been a lot of Ron Paul type
people are a lot of Rand Paul people at
see facts libertarians are just normal
people walking around here right now
well if foreign policy really is a
central issue for the Republican Party
in 2016 you sure couldn't tell by
looking at the schedule or walking
through the booths here when there's a
lot more to do with criminal justice
system than there is foreign policy also
those party professionals who talk and
think about foreign policy for a living
are still incredibly hawkish they want
to intervene they want to change regimes
in Iran and elsewhere and finally that's
not necessarily what the kids in the
floor are all about these days there's
still a split within the Republican
Party when it comes to basic questions
of foreign policy and intervention and
that debates going to be playing out
throughout the next 23 months for reason
TV I'm Matt Welch